Now, to qualify that title, pure alcohol will
absolutely kill brain cells and many other
types of cells, which is why it is used as
a disinfectant.
However, recent research has shown that the
quantity of alcohol you could possibly take
in, without killing yourself, does not introduce
enough alcohol into your bloodstream to kill
brain cells.
This was proven by a study by Grethe Jensen
and co.
(1993), who meticulously counted neurons in
matched samples of non-alcoholics and alcoholics.
What they found was that there was no real
difference in the density or overall number
of neurons between the two groups.
Various other research since has backed up
Jensen’s findings.
Thus, even alcoholics who are continually
taking in unhealthy amounts of alcohol aren’t
going to see brain cells die because of their
drinking problem.
However, alcohol does have other effects on
the brain, both positive and negative, that
have nothing to do with brain cells dying.
First, the positive: drinking moderate amounts
of alcohol on a regular basis has been shown
to have various positive effects on your body.
The one that pertains to this article’s
topic is that it has been shown to help protect
people from cognitive impairment as they age.
According to a study done at the Catholic
University of the Sacred Heart, in Italy,
29% of people 65 years or older who almost
never drank alcohol throughout their life
had mental impairment issues.
On the flip-side of that, only about 19% of
people 65 years or older who drank moderate
amounts of alcohol regularly had any mental
impairment.
It was further discovered that, among the
various groups where other problems, such
as health problems or the like, might impair
them mentally, the same trend appeared.
In every group, those who drank moderately
on a regular basis throughout their lives
always had a diminished chance of becoming
mentally impaired in their old age compared
to those who didn’t drink at all or almost
never drank.
Now for the negative (there’s a lot when
it comes to intemperate alcohol consumption,
so I’ll only cover a few): while brain cells
aren’t being killed as the result of drinking
excessive amounts of alcohol, the ability
for your brain cells to communicate with one
another is being inhibited.
What’s going on here is that the alcohol
ends up damaging dendrites, which are the
things at the ends of neurons that conduct
electrochemical stimulation from another cell
to the cell body in question.
Basically, with some of these dendrites damaged,
it inhibits the ability of your brain cells
to talk to one another.
Luckily, you have an amazing number of connections
and neurons in your brain (about 100 billion
neurons, along with 10’s of billions of
glial cells, which support the neurons).
So this helps mask the problem.
Also, even among long time alcoholics, it
has been shown that simply quitting drinking
copious amounts of alcohol is all that is
required for your body to be able to reverse
most of the damage to the dendrites and restore
the ability for your brain cells to communicate.
So you can afford to damage some of the neurons
temporarily without any real lasting effect.
Unfortunately, for the people who have an
extreme habit of excessively drinking, there
are other side effects on your brain that
aren’t so easily completely fixed, such
as developing Wernicke-Korsakoff syndrome,
which is characterized by: confusion, coordination
problems, hallucinations, memory problems,
eye problems, and even inducing a coma or
death, if it’s left untreated.
What’s going on here is that excessive alcohol
consumption over a long period of time causes
a vitamin B1 deficiency (8 out of 10 alcoholics
are vitamin B1 deficient), due to the alcohol
inhibiting the body’s ability to absorb
thiamine (also many alcoholics are often malnourished
because of their own bad eating habits).
This, in turn, causes neuron death, among
other things.
This is treatable, in most cases, but certain
effects stick around forever as your body
won’t be able to repair itself completely
from this particular brand of damage.
Another brain-related side effect caused by
excessive drinking is that high doses of alcohol,
while not killing your brain cells, inhibits
the growth of new brain cells.
However, recent research has shown, at least
with rats, that once the alcohol was no longer
given to the rats, new brain cell production
went into overdrive to try to compensate for
the previously inhibited brain cell production.
Now, if you go for long enough without giving
your brain a chance to recover, drinking excessively
on a regular basis, it is thought there may
still be lasting effects due to this inhibited
new brain cell growth over extended periods,
but whether this is actually the case or not,
isn’t yet known.
There are also a variety of other known neurological
problems that are associated with intemperate
alcohol consumptions over long periods of
time and some that even show up in a short
amount of time in children and teens who abuse
alcohol, but this article is already too long.
:-) Then of course, there are the myriad of
other problems, non-brain related that come
with alcoholism, such as liver problems, other
nervous system problems outside of how it
affects your brain, and others.
Bottom line, alcohol consumed in moderation,
such as a small glass of wine a day, can be
very good for you.
On the other hand, drinking excessively won’t
kill you brain cells directly, but is still
bad for your brain.
Although, your body can compensate, to a certain
extent, and repair the damage caused in most
cases, at least as far as your brain is concerned,
so long as you don’t make a regular habit
of it.
Bonus Facts:
Another myth concerning alcohol that was once
spread about, particularly during Prohibition,
but to which I don’t think anyone actually
believes anymore (at least I hope not!), is
that drinking excessive amounts of alcohol
can lead to spontaneous combustion due to
alcohol being flammable and it coursing through
your veins.
This is ridiculous on many levels, but nevertheless,
was a popular notion during Prohibition and
for a while afterwards.
The myth that alcohol kills brain cells was
also widely popularized during Prohibition.
There are several things that contribute to
hangovers, but principally what’s going
on here is simple dehydration.
Alcohol has a dehydrating effect by inhibiting
the release of vasopressin, which is an anti-diuretic
hormone.
So in layman’s terms, the result of alcohol
inhibiting the vasopressin is that your body
produces a lot more urine than normal with
the result that you become dehydrated easily.
Scientists once believed that the number of
nerve cells you have in your brain, once you
reach adulthood, was all you’d ever have.
Thus, damaging these cells could be extremely
detrimental to the individual.
However, this isn’t correct.
New neurons are created all the time in the
adult brain, in a process that is
called neurogenesis.